when rider's republic releases it'll be
known for many of its things it's good
things it's bad things but i think at
its heart it's going to be known for the
revival of the extreme sports genre
extreme sports have honestly been quite
lacking in recent years the sport
typically encompasses skateboarding
snowboarding skiing and bmx although
technically by definition it does have
sports that are high in speed and high
in danger so wingsuiting can count too
however when it comes to games in this
genre the only sport succeeding is
skating skate 3 and the upcoming skate 4
have been holding their own for years
and numerous other titles are being made
all the time like skater xl but the
others haven't had the opportunity to
really shine even if the community
reception was well received bmx games
like bmx the game and pipe were well
received by the community just not a
large community and ironically the last
snowboard game to get lots of attention
was steep also made by ubisoft so
writer's republic can be many things to
people but what you have to admit is
that it's a game that reunites a
community of fans this is the game that
people can go to for extreme sports or
at least the aforementioned sports it's
not only got a ton of marketing and
attention from the gaming world but it's
made by a triple a developer with more
than enough money and time to update the
game it's like a beacon of light for
fans who won the ultimate extreme sports
game and to a degree be ubisoft has
delivered so today i want to discuss
with you my time with rogers republic
and what my overall thoughts are so
let's get started to get the legal stuff
out of the way a big thank you to
ubisoft for providing me with the code
to not only play the game a couple days
early but also giving me four more hours
than everyone else in the trial those
eight hours were very much needed so i
appreciate it as always the story
premise is pretty close if not exactly
like forza horizon where the yearly
festival called the writers republic is
making the rounds again and thousands of
people have shown up to enjoy it while
this can be seen as copying personally i
really don't blame them it's hard to
make a story where 99 of the game is
based around the gameplay so a quick
explanation is really all you need so
something as basic as a festival is
totally fine and really shouldn't be
analyzed any deeper next is that
gameplay loop i'll briefly go over
what's available then give my thoughts
after so for the gameplay loop this will
consist of you participating in events
to earn stars these stars unlock either
new events or later can unlock other
unique items like titles or the
legendary gold smoke mask but stars
aren't earned from just events as there
are landmarks mass races and
sponsorships that you can earn stars in
for a quick rule of thumb just about
everything in the game will earn you a
star and if it doesn't earn you stars
it'll give you in-game currency going
back to those events you have numerous
things to participate in events are
split into three categories air snow and
bmx each of them have their own race and
trick events they're fairly
self-explanatory be the first to cross
the finish line in the race event and be
the one with the most points in the
trick event these can either be played
solo which is you in roughly 11 other ai
players or in a versus mode but it seems
to be just teammates in your group so
you can start some personal rivalries
you'll not only be getting a star for
completing the event but you'll also
earn more stars from the secondary
objectives which can reward up to six
these are challenges like beating it
within a specific time pulling off a
specific trick or completing it using an
ice cream bike you can also do the same
event over and over again and still earn
stars i don't know if this is entirely
intended but one of the snow trick
events that i did i started with 144 and
i didn't even do any tricks in the event
i actually just raced to the finish line
and got zero points but despite me not
only completing this before but also
coming in last place i still got a star
for it i doubt this counts as a farming
method for the game but it's something
to take into account when playing after
doing these small events you'll be able
to unlock a bigger events which you can
see from the career menu but you'll also
be able to track your specific careers
level each level you earn earns you
equipment with better stats this could
lead to some issues with people stomping
the competition with equipment that has
better stats but from the time that i've
been playing it seems to still be about
skill level and not the equipment if the
ai is boring you then you can try your
handed mass races and the competitive
modes competitive events are the same as
the previous ones mentioned except
there's the skill ranking and the trick
events are actually team based mode mass
races happen every hour on the hour
within the game and are 30 to 60 plus
player races spanning many different
styles you can go from biking to jet
packs back to biking in one continuous
race individually i think they're fun
and unique the beauty of this game is
that because there's so many options for
all the equipment if you want to partake
in one particular sport you can however
it's also the game's problem this game
isn't simply about picking up one sport
then staying with it the game really
does push you to do all of them as
evidenced by the mass races and what
we'll get into now the progress tracker
i've already technically talked about
the tracker before but i haven't
explained the beginning part of it like
i said before the game has three
different sports with two different
events in each minus those competitive
modes and the mass races that is a total
of six different events you can unlock
and do it sounds as simple as picking up
one sport doing the events then after a
couple stars you get to pick the next
sport if you thought this however you
are wrong instead of going in order like
i just described the game is all over
the place in the exact order of bike
races snow tricks both of the air events
at the same time then bike tricks and
snow races how this was ever greenlit is
bizarre to me but also a problem for
specific people like me someone who
enjoys the snow sports more than
anything i have to wait to get 90 stars
just for a simple snow race which at
least in my playtime took me five and a
half hours to get i understand why they
did this as within the game's world the
main hub is on grass so picking a
snowboard and only staying with that for
a while probably wouldn't be a good idea
but regardless it is very confusing and
quite overwhelming at some points but
also really annoying to players who just
want to race in the snow hey so quick
editor's note i forgot to add this but
ubisoft you need to add a stance option
in the settings for the snowboards the
default position for the snowboards in
rider's republic is regular but i prefer
to play in goofy so every time i start a
new race or fall over i need to switch
my stance because the game has no option
for it by default it's downright
unacceptable speaking of overwhelming
the actual equipment you get can be a
bit much at certain points each one of
these events has different equipment so
bike races only allow downhill or road
bikes but bike tricks only allow
freestyle and slope style bikes if
you're well versed in the sport this
could be a huge positive as it seems
like they're trying to be as accurate as
possible but as someone not familiar
with many of these it just kind of seems
like the same bike the game does do a
good job of kind of letting you know
what bike you'll be using so if you do a
downhill bike race you'll be using
downhill bikes and road bike races will
be using road bikes but still most
players probably won't care but i think
ubisoft knew this would happen as
everything in the game is rated by a
number and a higher obviously means
better so i'd normally just pick the
highest number and go on my way for the
events themselves they're actually quite
fun and really exhilarating there's
something about going 50 miles per hour
down a slope only to have it turn at the
end where one wrong move can send you
off the cliff that is just so fun the
races are where the majority of that
style of gameplay will take place and
it's strongly recommended from me at
least to not do tricks during the
regular race as you're not going to get
any points for it and you're just
setting yourself up for failure most of
the skill for this race comes down to
precision and speed being able to handle
the fast speeds while also moving around
obstacles is key and was very fun even
if most of the time i would wipe out for
the trick events i feel the same way
these are less intense as you're not
bound by other racers but by the number
of tricks you can perform in a specific
run the trick courses give you a set
amount of tricks you can perform as to
not cheat and do a hundred of them on
the way down so expending all of your
tricks too early will leave you with a
long drive of no points and possibly
missing out on the bigger ramps and
finishing the race with tricks left over
is a waste of potential points so it's
this combination of doing enough tricks
but not too many too early and also
doing the complex tricks that net more
points both the race and trig events
clearly show a skill curve that allows
the players who really know what they're
doing to succeed which means it makes
the game more competitive encouraging
you to get better yourself which then
leads to more playtime and ultimately
more fun with great rewards as now you
can pull off those bizarre tricks and
maneuvers you didn't think were possible
the last modes we haven't discussed yet
in detail are the mass races and the
competitive modes the mass races are
essentially ubisoft's magnum opus the
one thing that they've been advertising
to death about the game and as i
mentioned before they're 30 to 60 player
races that happen every hour i mean this
in no exaggeration this is the best
content in the entire game nothing in
this game could top how fun these were
it's the complete test of skill as it
goes through all the different sports
and forces you to be skillful in all of
them in the beginning though you could
be going strong in first until one
slight miscalculation brings you to the
back of the group but remember everyone
is just as susceptible to this as you
and now you could be in the front again
with a flawless performance and ending
on a strong finish the beauty of this
game mode is nothing can be used as an
excuse the game provides the players
with the exact same thing everyone knows
what different segments are a part of
the race ahead of time and everyone
wears the same clothes and equipment so
nothing is unfair if you end up in last
place it's purely on you and
alternatively if you end up in first
it's also purely under skill the races
are three rounds and depending on your
position at the end you'll receive some
points after all three rounds everyone's
points are totaled to showcase the final
ranking not only does this give you
bragging rights if you win but you also
gain lots of stars the highest i've ever
gotten is 7th place but that's still
quite impressive considering 29 other
people were racing against me regardless
it's the best content in the game and
some of the most fun i've had with this
game for the competitive modes you have
two options there is the free-for-all
section and the trick battle section
available at the home base free for all
is a 12-man race just like many of the
race events that you've been doing
except with real people and there's a
ranking system i'm assuming these races
are gonna go across all the sports mode
since i did play a bike and a ski race
so it's safe to assume that all races
will be included for the trick battles
currently it's just a 6v6 snow tricks
battle you get put on a team of six
people and have to perform different
tricks on various ramps and railings
when you perform a trick it gets lit up
in blue and the enemy is in red if one
team captures a whole section they get
five times the points for performing
tricks in that sector this was honestly
really fun and encourages sticking with
the team but also performing major
tricks and is a really cool way of
learning tricks if you haven't tried any
yet seeing his bikes to my knowledge
cannot grind on ledges or rails it seems
that this may be for snow sports only
however there's nothing stopping them
from adding a different arena more
tailored towards bikes for this game
mode after any of these matches if you
win you'll increase your division rank
and lose rank if you lose just like any
other competitive game mode there seems
to be an entry fee for these matches as
you're essentially wagering your
division points it seems that in
division 10 there is no fee but when you
get to division nine there's a fee of
five division points but at division
nine you do gain five points for losing
so it seems like the first couple
divisions there isn't a major penalty
for losing just yet although i assume
that would get more punishing the higher
you go up your total divisions points
get added to the weekly division level
on the left hand side you can then gain
more items in gear while you go higher
however this is where i'm a little
confused there's also a timer in the top
right this is most likely a timer that
resets the mode but what does it reset
the division ranks the weekly level the
game modes maybe all of them this sadly
is the one thing i fully don't
understand about the game but it doesn't
seem to be that big of a deal and
judging by the fact that both game modes
have separate locations at the main hub
this leads me to believe that there will
be multiple game modes per week because
i feel like leaving all this empty room
on screen just does not make sense as a
final note on the game modes i think
writer's republic does a good job with
them there is a lot of options that give
everyone at least something to enjoy and
an adequate amount of challenge to the
events that'll give you a reason to
continue playing and getting better at
the game the only thing we haven't
discussed yet in terms of gameplay is
tricks and it's going to sound a bit
confusing in the beginning hopefully i
can kind of explain it a bit better also
be using the xbox and playstation
buttons on screen just so there's a
visual example so you have three preset
options for tricks racer uses the
buttons trickster uses the right
thumbstick and the third uses the
triggers and bumpers apparently this is
the same control scheme for steep so if
you play steep this might be a bit
easier to use they all pretty much
function the same way pressing a is like
flicking the thumbstick down and
pressing b is like flicking it to the
right for those buttons x and b are for
spins b goes to the right x goes to the
left y and a are for the flips y is a
front flip and a is a backflip you can
however also use the triggers in racer
and trickster mode to do grabs there's a
left grab only using the left trigger
right grabs are for only using the right
trigger and a double grab is when you
use both you can obviously do something
more than just grabbing the board as if
you flick the thumbstick in any
direction that produces a varying amount
of different moves all this together can
look really cool and allow you to pull
off some crazy tricks but the question
is how do you start one in games like
skate 3 a method grab is used by pulling
the right trigger and pushing the left
thumbstick in a specific direction but
to get any air off the jump you need to
do an ollie or kickflip to actually get
the air for it so what's that button for
rider's republic
it's all the face buttons
yeah the buttons used for the tricks are
also the ones for the jumps
i figured this out in the main hub when
i first played as i pressed every single
button on flat ground and i jumped after
everyone like i said it's gonna get a
little confusing so to hopefully explain
a bit better let me go over a front flip
the game does a decent job of explaining
that you press and hold one button when
approaching the ramp then press and hold
another when you get to the top of the
ramp to perform the trick so to do a
front flip you could do y then y again
that's a front flip but you can also do
a then y to do a front flip so now
you're starting to think that as long as
the last button is y it's a front flip
that would be wrong that's only if the
buttons are similar remember a and y are
the only ones that do flips so
technically this works but if you work
in buttons like x or b you'll do a
hybrid trick of both a spin and a flip
to make this a little easier let me show
you step by step a trick i pulled off
incorporating all of this for a more
visual example so to start the race i
hold the right trigger as with any
racing game left trigger is break right
trigger is accelerate as i approach the
ramp i hold the a button to start the
first part i could then press y into a
front flip but instead as we approach
the top of the ramp i let go of the
right trigger and a this means my
character starts the jump we then very
quickly will press down both the
triggers and x and since we went from a
to x we're doing both a spin and a flip
and then since we're using both triggers
we do a double grab at the same time
turning into this
this is just one move or one combination
of buttons and it sounds really
confusing but you'll actually benefit
from doing this yourself rather than
someone explaining it like me because it
becomes muscle memory quite fast there
is a way to help you with tricks at the
main hub which is the trick academy you
simply just select whatever trick you
want to do and the game gives you a
large course and enough room to perform
them at least a dozen times so after all
of this what trick system do you use if
it wasn't obvious by the buttons used
throughout this demonstration i would
say the racer both of them have
incredibly annoying problems with them
but the trickster is by far the worst at
least in my opinion a mechanic i have
yet to bring up is backtracking should
you fall or miss a checkpoint you can
use backtrack which transports you back
a few seconds this doesn't reset time
for everyone else only moves you back a
bit so everyone is still racing at
normal speed the problem with racer is
that the buttons to continue after
backtracking is the a button the same as
the trick button and if you're in the
heat of the race and press it too many
times you might press a to jump causing
you to miss once again this is the same
but arguably worse if you've fallen off
your bike since you have to mash b to
get back on and once again that's a
trick button so there's been numerous
times where i've lost races because of
this however because tricksters use the
right thumbstick for their tricks their
camera is permanently locked to the
position of the racer so you cannot move
the camera and seeing as the fov in this
game is extremely low with no option to
increase it on console you're really
screwing yourself over but that's just
my opinion overall there's lots of depth
to these tricks as there are some simple
tricks like a front flip but then
there's the ones as complicated as the
example i gave it's this loop of getting
the hang of a new trick then attempting
new ones before those become muscle
memory then you move on to the next one
until most of the trick list is
ingrained into you the very last thing
we haven't touched in this video is free
roam mode if you want to race down hills
by yourself or just fly throughout the
map you can do that the map of rider's
republic is quite large and has various
areas in the game for all sports there's
the snowy mountains in the west a dry
desert area in the southeast and even a
forest area dead middle of the map
throughout it though you'll be seeing
loads of icons anything in white as an
ai and anything in orange is a real
player this edition is great and it
makes it feel like a real festival with
thousands of people who all came to ride
together so it's nice to be able to see
other people and even the ais doing
tricks alongside you the place you'll be
visiting the most is the rider's ridge
the home base of the game it has
everything you'll need in regards to
matchmaking training and customization
we've discussed most of this already
throughout the video but as for the only
place we haven't mentioned yet there is
a store that is basically the in-game
item shop these function very similar to
any game that's added in item shop in
the recent years and obviously the good
stuff will be locked behind a paywall
personally i've never liked item shops
but i thought i'd mention it anyway so
you know what you're getting into during
the game after about a one hour tutorial
you are then eventually encouraged to
explore parts of the map the map is
greyed out for the most part and needs
to be unlocked by traveling through the
map this is a very typical formula of
ubisoft's other games like far cry and
assassin's creed and just like those
games leave it to ubisoft to add
collectibles in a game like this there
are 45 landmarks 23 stunts 11 relics and
a whopping 500 balloons the landmarks
were cool after i found out that most if
not all of them are actual real
locations which is real nice and the
stunts are pretty nice too they do
provide a bit more challenge than your
typical events already present in the
game for example the first one is
actually at the main hub it's this very
hard obstacle course that needs to be
beaten in three minutes the relics are
weird equipment called funkies i haven't
mentioned this but there is a group of
riders called the shack daddy bandits
they're famous for doing bizarre stunts
with very weird equipment like wing
suiting with a cardboard plane or using
skis made of old wood they also have
their own events and challenges but
regardless they are pretty cool it's
nice to see some bizarre and wacky
equipment you can use in the game
however the 500 balloons are insane
they're not marked on the map and
they'll only give you a small bit of
money you could claim that it's for the
seasoned player who wants to explore
every inch of the map but i think that's
a poor excuse in an attempt to defend
them ubisoft really wants to get away
from their tried and true formula with
this game but not too far apparently as
they need to add some sort of
collectible with an astronomical number
it's like the borgia flags of assassin's
creed it's just flat out boring content
and not worth your time besides the
collectibles you have a large map that
you can ride and traverse but i'm
confused about what this game wants if
this game was mainly focused on
completing events and getting stars then
they succeeded but then it feels like
you're just going through a checklist
and taking off boxes the best part about
any of these games is the ability to
ride for hours you could run the same
course over and over again or just go
down a path and see where it takes you
but if they tried to do that then they
barely succeeded the best places to get
that thrill of riding your snowboard or
bike is the courses the game gives you
they're used in the events so why not
use them in the free roam mode they're
obviously the best places to ride down
this works perfectly with the snow
events as there's a ski lift at the
bottom of most of the courses that'll
take you right back up to the top and
you can continue riding again but for
the bikes there is nothing if you want
to ride the same course you need to go
to the course's start then once you
finish or are satisfied with your run
you have to fast travel to a nearby
location then bike your way over to the
starting line again depending on the
course this fast travel could be
thousands of feet away so you're not
even riding to the course anymore you're
just flying to the course every time you
want to reset i think you can understand
how boring this would get this game
needs some sort of checkpoint system
like how skate 3 implemented where if
you want to reset you can just be sent
back to the checkpoint that you put down
because right now i cannot see myself
constantly teleporting and traveling to
a course which might be longer than the
actual course itself however before you
start the game there is an option called
the zen mode which apparently according
to ubisoft as i asked them through email
is an offline mode for the game so maybe
there's something like that in there or
maybe i'm just trying to cope regardless
the exploration does have some real
potential and certain areas are really
fun to explore but most of the fun i had
was running the same snow course for an
hour straight and while i may be in the
minority when it comes to people
enjoying that kind of gameplay i
definitely can't be alone as an overall
note to writer's republic is a really
good game it has a 60 price tag so you
do with that as you will but from what
i've experienced the game is quite fun
and it's a game i'll definitely be
playing in my spare time whenever i have
limited time before something i can
always just load the game up right
around for 10 to 15 minutes then turn it
off but it's also beneficial for those
who want to play for hours and hours at
a time of course it's always up to you
whether or not you want to buy the game
with that however we have come to the
end of the video let me know what you
think about writer's republic down below
and if you did participate in that trial
week before the game's launch do let me
know what you thought about the game as
well like the video if you enjoyed
subscribe if you're new and as always if
you're a returning viewer i thank you
for coming back
take care everyone
and goodbye
[Music]
you